[Music]
fans are shipping Shawn Mendes and
Camilla Kibeho hard and the pair is
totally playing into it yeah we're
trying to get to the bottom of whether
shamela is real starting with this
that's Shawn and Camilla with their
hands all over each other the two were
photographed out in LA over the weekend
holding hands hugging and looking very
happy to be out together for their
Sunday brunch date if that's not PDA I
don't know what is that PDA pact outing
came just one day after Camilla
reportedly went to Shawn's LA concert
for the second time to support him she
was also there on Friday night adding
fuel to the dating rumors by posting two
super mushy Instagram stories about
Shawn during his show including this one
that read Shawn Mendes you couldn't be
more amazing and this one that included
the words Wow and a heart emoji
[Music]
and get this guy's after his show on
Saturday the two were reportedly spotted
cozying up together at a restaurant in
LA at 4:47 a.m. yeah that's apparently
Shawn with his arm around Camila can you
even stand the cuteness
I can't number five on our list that
sexy steamy seniorita music video guys
you just can't fake that kind of
chemistry and just days after releasing
the video Camila and Shawn were snapped
holding hands while walking to the front
door of his pad the next day they
arrived together at Nobu Malibu for a
party an eyewitness told et that it
appeared to be a quote date night for
the two who didn't leave each other's
side adding quote his arm was around her
at their table they held hands and were
seen kissing on the lips the pair
arrived and left the party together now
this long-awaited coupling would make
total sense right now Camila just split
from her boyfriend of more than a year
Matthew Hussey but Shawn did seemingly
shut down the rumors of their romance
when a fan asked him point-blank about
it during a recent low-key Q&A
[Music]
that was the best setup - will you go
with me okay but he didn't actually say
no and look how fast he reaches for his
water a telltale sign of nerves of
course fans have been rooting for
shamela since their first collab I know
what you did last summer dropped in 2015
when Sean told et this you guys have
said multiple times that you're just
friends but your fans still think that
there's something more going on set the
record straight
no we are just friends besides we're not
dating like you guys to write more songs
together
she's amazing like super talented his
songwriter like I've never worked with
the extra songwriter who I clicked with
as well as her so definitely that still
sounds like love to me
but of course et will be here to bring
you all the latest Sean and Camila news
so make sure to keep it locked right
here on ET until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now